we talked a bit about the hard way you
know people are working on the hardware
of quantum computing yeah software
writing software for a quantum computer
in my opinion is actually not very very
different from how we write software for
just a normal computer and we think
about software in terms of being able to
write down instructions for the computer
and the computer executing these
instructions changing some internal
state when I write instructions for any
type of computer whether it be like a
modern MacBook Pro or an old PDP 11 in
both cases in the end we have an
assembly code that gets executed that's
changing the the memory the disk the
registers in your CPU and so on and it's
not different with a quantum computer
it's just like the question is what are
we changing and how do we change them we
can really describe these things in
quite simple terms if we were to do this
in with sort of full textbook honesty we
would discuss things like finite
dimensional vector spaces and in Hilbert
spaces and linear operators and unitary
maps and all that stuff and all that
stuff is very very important if if
you're actually sitting down writing a
program but to get an understanding of
it I think we can do away with it and
actually just think about things in
terms of simple probabilities so the
idea of a qubit yep it is yeah it's sort
of the fundamental building block it's
like a it's like a bit and a regular
computer
the way I think of it is it's a resource
in the computer it's a resource that you
can use to perform a computation so a
qubit to me is anything it's sort of
abstract but anything that has two
states of being
and some possibility or probability of
those states so for instance we can
think about photons and their
polarization a photon can be sort of
polarized left and right or it can be
polarized up and down but if we're not
looking then maybe it's it's possibly in
one or the other maybe it's 50% moving
and traversing left and right and 50%
moving
up and down this is just for photons
turns out there are lots and lots of
different ways to construct qubits the
qubits that that we work on in the so
called field of superconducting quantum
computation we use a device called a
superconducting charge qubit it doesn't
matter all the details but it suffice to
say that the two states there are is
their charge or is there no charge in
this circuit and then of course we have
the same thing it could we could have a
probability like maybe there's a 10%
chance there's a charge or maybe there's
a 90% chance there's a charge these are
called superconducting charge qubits
again it sounds complicated but the
essence is the same two states but maybe
it's in one or the other the interesting
thing though is when we have multiple
qubits and this is really where the
power of quantum computation happens we
can actually think of it sort of simply
diagrammatically that if qubits if I
just represent them sort of as a circle
here maybe we have three the idea is
that these qubits can interact this guy
can interact with this guy this guy can
interact with this guy and these can
interact with one another and every time
we add a qubit if we were to add a
circle here let's say we added this
fourth qubit right here we noticed that
every single one of them can now
interact with it we have to draw lots of
these lines it turns out that a quantum
computer can deal with these additions
of qubits in a very efficient fashion
but like I said a qubit is something
where it has two states so each of these
guys can be in two states with a
particular probability let's say the two
states and our just zero and one our
qubit can be 0 or 1 or possibly
something in between so if I write down
these qubits with the probability let's
say we have three qubits here I'll call
it q0 q1 and q2 what we have is that
qubit 0 let's say it's this one right
here 1 and 2 well cubed 0 could be in 0
or 1 so it has some probability of being
in 0 keep it 1 also has some probability
of being in 0 and cubed 0 also has some
probability being in 0 maybe that's a
10% chance but now we have to
painstakingly go through a right every
one cubed 0 has a probability of being
in the 0 state qubit 1 also 0 and qubit
to 1 and we can
down all these possibilities etc etc
until we get to the possibility that all
of them are one and each of them has a
probability maybe this is 5% maybe this
is 7% maybe this is like 35% maybe
there's a very high percentage chance
that all of them are one 8% and so on so
every time we add a cubit the size of
this table doubles the number of
probability percentages doubles and it
turns out that these probabilities right
here are ultimately what a quantum
computer is computing with when we do an
instruction on a Kanna computer when we
instruct it to do something in the end
it's always about changing these
probabilities to favor some computation
that we're trying to do when we start up
a quantum reader when we flick the
switch on it'll start as 100% in this
state and everything else will be 0% we
start off here and we know that we start
off here it might be that when we apply
a certain operation so for example an
operation as is the so called
superposition initialization or we call
it Hadamard initialization this is if we
have any number of qubits so starting
off in zero and maybe we want every
probability to be equal so if we want to
start off here we do something called
Hadamard initialization where we do a
particular instruction called the
Hadamard gate and what happens is this
100% now turns into let's say we just
have one qubit it would be 50% chance in
the zero State and 50% chance in the one
state if we had two qubits Hadamard
initialization would cause us to be 25%
chance with both qubits being 0 25%
chance 0 1 25% chance being 1 0 25%
chance being 1 1 the point is is that
this particular instructions one
instruction on a quantum computer allows
us to change these probabilities in a
way that we'd like and it might be
useful for us to do something like this
Hadamard initialization with all the
probabilities being equal because then
from here we could do some operation
that affects all these qubits and
affects all these probabilities sort of
in the same way but like I said this is
just one possible instruction so there
can be an infinite number just like a
normal computer it's not that they're an
infinite number of instructions it's
that they're an infant
of possible things you could do with the
instructions so one of the greatest
discoveries was that we can arrange
these probabilities to be in whatever
way that we would like using five
instructions total there are sort of
five different ways that we can permute
these things and change them and there
this one is called a measure instruction
measure instruction is pretty important
because while we're talking about
probabilities we can actually see these
probabilities in the quantum computer
they're just in there at some point we
do want to see are they zeros or ones
like we need to answer that question so
the measure instruction will take any
list of probabilities and turn it into
one of them will change to 100% so each
of these is 25% chance it'll pick one
let's say it's this one right here and
measure is gonna make this a hundred
percent with the other ones being zero
percent that's one way of changing and
then incidentally we also get to read
out from the clunkier that it was a one
zero that's how we get our answers
that's the only way we get an answer in
fact from the quantum computer the rest
of them are just purely ways of changing
these probabilities there are lots of
different ways you can have instruction
just like Nora computers every single
computer that's ever been built or every
single CPU that server been built always
has a different instruction set one
possible instruction set is the
following we have this Hadamard yes it's
named after I think he was a
mathematician he worked on a variety of
mathematical subjects and there's a
matrix that's actually one divided by
square root of 2 1 1 1 negative 1 which
is a so-called Hadamard matrix
incidentally this is also used to
represent how these probabilities change
so Hadamard is one instruction there's
another instruction called phase again
it just has the effect of changing
probabilities around in a particular way
there's another instruction called the T
gate not very creatively named there's
another instruction called the C naught
gate and what's special to C naught gate
is that all of these right here act on
one qubit we say I want to do a measure
on qubit 2 or I want to do a t gate on
cubed zero
it sort of affects only one qubit it'll
affect a lot of probabilities because
even though we're operating on one qubit
here it accounts for this entire column
so it actually chain
is all the probabilities see not as
special is because we get to choose two
qubits this is how we get this
interaction between them so see not you
can say I want to do this on cubed 0 and
cubit 2 for instance and this itself is
an instruction in a sort of quantum
assembly code yes so they are like gates
but there's an interesting reversal and
for example an and gate is something
like this where data is coming into the
gate and data comes out of the gate
what's interesting about these gates and
quantum computation is sort of the
opposite you have data that's sitting
there all these probabilities and you
like apply the gate to the Machine and
all the probabilities change so you're
not sending data into the gate you're
not putting this gate on the chip like a
NAND gate for instance is a gate that
you would actually etch into a chip here
it's an instruction that you apply to
the computer and it changes these
probabilities but nonetheless they're
both different operations that you do on
data and how does what you do is code
get changed into these operations of
instructions yeah so like with normal
computers you can write these
instructions out as assembly code in
fact one example is say I want the
following probabilities I have 0 0 0 1 1
0 1 1 I want this I want it to be 50%
chance to be 0 0 or 50% chance to be 1 1
this is called a bell state with a bell
state it's interesting because
theoretically let's suppose I have a
qubit let's say close I could hold a
qubit and let's say I gave you a qubit
it's 50% chance 0 0 or 50% chance 1 1 so
even if we travelled halfway across the
world and I decided to measure my qubit
with the measure instruction and I
determine that to 0 then I know for
certain that you must be 0 because
there's a zero percent chance that were
different but somehow we determine this
it's a 50% chance it's not that it is
already chosen literally is 50% chance
you don't know which one it is so we can
write a program to construct a bell
state I won't explain exactly why it
works this way but you do a Hadamard on
my qubit cubed 0 we do a C not on my
qubit and your
and we're done this is a quantum program
you can write this out now there are
higher levels of quantum programming
where we don't want to restrict
ourselves these instructions maybe I
want to more directly Express the
probabilities and how I want them to
change they all have to add up to 1 of
course I mean we have a certain
percentage chance it has to be 100% in
the end but maybe I want to shift the
probabilities around in a particular way
but not in any of the ways that's in our
gate set I can write that down that can
use something called a quantum compiler
a piece of software that that converts
what I want into these native
instructions that gives me the next
level of abstraction in the code we can
go all the way up to using a full-blown
library for writing this stuff one
library that we've constructed is
something called PI quill which allows
us to actually write Python code to
express quantum computations in quill is
actually this instruction set here quill
stands for quantum instruction language
which lets you write down this assembly
code yeah yeah so quill was originally
this this particular type of instruction
set was a paper that I actually wrote a
while ago the idea of gates and
everything was very well known for for
many decades previous to that so this is
a particular encoding of gates as
instructions pi quill is a library
that's open source it's free there are
no restrictions really on using it to
construct these programs but it does
allow you to actually connect up to
Righetti Computing's real quantum
computers if you if you so pleased to
actually run your programs but if you
don't want to connect up to the quantum
computers and you just want to simulate
on your own laptop this can connect up
to a an open source simulation tool that
we have if you just kind of want to see
how these probabilities change and so on
not quite you still have to express a
quantum computation so a quantum
computer doesn't doesn't print things
out it's it's it's manipulative so at
some point you stuff to express things
as quantum instructions so definitely if
you wanted to make a bell state writing
the bell state program you could do that
but could you write hello world no and
this goes back to the fact that
the quantum computer is a coprocessor
just like saying you don't write hello
world on your GPU generally you don't
express any particular computation and
you also don't compile Python into code
on your GPU you write special code
within Python that gets run on your GPU
and it's the same thing with quantum
computing ability issues do you get
hauled out today so yeah so when an
answer comes out when you measure you do
get definite answer out
however since there's noise what we have
to do is write our program get an answer
out and store that and actually rerun it
multiple times we have to gather
statistics about the answer and it turns
out that the more you do this the more
accurate your answers become and that is
to account for noise in the quantum
computer currently yeah no you don't
know the answer you just show that if
you were to do this series of operations
that you'd get the right answer on the
answer might be different Japan and if
ur --nt depending on the problem that
you have so for instance one of the main
questions the quantum computer can solve
is the same question that you can get
from something called the Fourier
transform where you can find if you have
like a sound wave and you want to find
what frequencies it has you know that if
you run the Fourier transform proven
using mathematics and so on that the
answer will be the set of frequencies
that make up that sound likewise here
there's actually something called a
quantum Fourier transform where if you
run it you know that probabilities will
accumulate on the answers or the
frequencies maybe that your that your
sound wave has so you know just by the
construction of your program that you'll
get the correct answer not that you know
the correct answer itself at the front
end and that's the same with classical
computing in my opinion you rarely do
you know what the final answer is you
just know the computation or the program
that you've written will produce the
correct answer
okay so she will my question cuz I will
never goes for sensory advice to have
multiple qubits you need more than one
qubit to make this work you can use a
qubit if you have a normal qubit your
table is gonna look like this you're
gonna have prob and maybe it's like 50%
50% in your states are just 0 & 1 except
they're just not very many useful things
you can do with a single qubit the power
really comes from multiple qubits
because you get this nice scaling law
where if you have n qubits the number of
probabilities that you get to work with
is 2 to the power of n so every single
additional qubit you're doubling the
number of probabilities how do you know
how to do that for a regular computer
though
well I suppose with a regular computer
if you're if you're adding numbers
together yep something comes out mm-hmm
it's the same thing at the quantum
computer your input is a bunch of
probabilities which you know at the very
start and all these gates change those
probabilities in a controlled way you
know exactly how had a Mart or phase or
T or C not you know exactly how it's
gonna change those and you can write
down exactly how it'll change those so
you can mechanically do the computation
in the same way that we can mechanically
do it with adders or ale use or whatever
just turns out that the most basic type
of computation is actually a really it's
a really large one it's it's actually
equivalent to a big matrix multiply if
you were to write this out your
probabilities as a column vector 50% 25%
whatever 7% etc etc every operation
laQuan computer is actually specified as
a matrix you have a big set of matrix
elements maybe it's like 1 0 0 0 0 0 0 0
1 1/2 3/4 whatever I'm making it up as I
go along of course but you know with
certainty 100% certainty that this
operation maybe this is like Hadamard on
cubed 0 and
Hadamard on cuba 1 or something like
that it's not but you know that this
operation is gonna change his
probabilities and I could if I wanted to
manually go and compute this matrix
multiplication the thing is like I said
this vector right here grows doubles in
size every time I add a qubit so it's
better for a quantum computer to do it
as opposed to me or even a normal
computer doing it yes yes yep this
multiplication happens on the order of
50 to 250 nanoseconds on a computer no
matter the number of qubits that you
have even if you have 250 qubits this
vector right here would be 2 to the
power of 250 which is some enormous lis
large number I don't even know an order
of magnitude estimate of what that is
it's so bigger than any computer on
earth could store bigger than any
computer in the universe could store but
nonetheless it will do this
multiplication in 50 nanoseconds which
really starts getting into why quantum
computers show promise for very fast or
very powerful applications oh my gosh
all the components it costs a great deal
for sure if you want to buy one and have
it in your living room yeah so one of
the big popular ones is a very recent
algorithm back in I think 2014 is when I
came out is this variational quantum
eigen solver the technical disk